hey how's it going bros my name is Peter
Pat so I made a promise to you yesterday
or two days ago that I was gonna replay
so that we can get a better ending
because I personally hated the ending
that we got and I don't think you
brothers liked it either and I I read a
lot of your comments and apparently I
only have to replay two episodes that's
the problem I have to replay both of
them and I have to do it perfectly but
technically only two episodes number six
and nine and I have to make a couple
changes and that way we will get the
ending that we want where everyone lives
supposedly I might [ __ ] up anything
anyway but I'm gonna try for you bros
and it's gonna be a law a lot of playing
now so and a lot of me not talking so
I'll probably just cut something
together enjoy you can't skip the
cutscenes ah okay so now we're gonna go
to the radio tower and what I'm supposed
to do is there's the flare gun alright
there we go let's get that thing is
what's gonna save Maddie be my boo let's
write mad at B give it to Maddie B this
is how we're gonna live yes no no no
don't shoot what the [ __ ] that's the
problem he shoots it wait we have to
disagree with Emily oh god that's in
another episode uh where is Oh God
this is more complex than I thought oh
okay I'm reading like a lot err to make
sure that it's done correct because I
don't wanna let you brush down someone
is saying that Matt can survive if he
agrees with Emily and shoots the gun
when handed to him to do so you must
jump the first time and do not same
Emily so let's just try that if that
works I'm gonna be so [ __ ] happy
here we go Maddy B is back come on this
has to work
I swear to god I'm gonna cry a million
rivers of Tears sorry [ __ ] so mad at me
hurry there's no time save yourself
[Music]
sorry I really gotta jump Emily
butterfly effects update Maddy P is
alive and breathing
mad abuse my BAE and my boo boo boo here
comes another crucial thing that we need
to do for Ashley and okay what is his
name again Chris Wright and remember
yeah so we got to make sure that Chris
does not shoot Ashley Ashley will
apparently not open the door later like
let me do with it she's really
convincing
man he really seemed like Chris died
there all right all right all right
okay so that was episode 16 how does it
save does it save like I'm worried if I
go out then it won't save so now
technically we have to do episode 8 as
well because I [ __ ] up with
[ __ ] Chris and we're gonna do
that and hopefully it [ __ ] works the
[ __ ] does happen oh god it crashed know
what that [ __ ] don't tell me I just lost
what we just did oh god it didn't save
look at this look at this [ __ ] [ __ ]
it didn't [ __ ] save Chris shot Ashley
that's [ __ ] apparently you can't
replay the changes it doesn't change
[ __ ] it's just a way to get collectibles
okay you're gonna have to go with Plan B
here and just play the final the second
final chapter and save Jessica and
[ __ ] whatever the jogger pants
Sam
okay oh god I'm so tired
I wouldn't honestly I would replay
everything is just that Marcia spires is
coming over and I don't have that much
time today that's why I'm getting so
stressed out over it whoa did you notice
that Josh got killed right away that
didn't happen last time today I think we
got a secret ending last time okay
finally oh my god I played one in a half
hour almost two hours sorry just for
[ __ ] Jessica at this point
oh god this one stupid mistake I made to
supers missed three maybe four fine hide
there you go
I want to blow out your candle bro
yay break there I'm not gonna run that's
that's for [ __ ] sure go Jesse Kay
[Music]
that ass nice that wendi-go ass when did
it go in my hand oh god what that [ __ ]
what's that
Jessica lives high-five oh my god so
much effort
hey what oh my god yes we're gonna hide
[Music]
Jesus Christ
I didn't even breathe
the [ __ ] Smeagol from Lord of the
Rings or some [ __ ]
thank God run oh we did it
[ __ ] gonna live
oh wow
about a five pick okay let's look at the
ending that we worked so hard
[Music]
where's Maddie though
[Music]
[ __ ] I refuse to accept that so Josh
actually lived in our first playthrough
that's really weird
I hate you oh my god the penis the joke
is carried and taken what did you think
I don't know I don't know
hmm if you need someone to talk to and
fine
sometimes after a traumatic experience I
said I'm fine
Oh your friend Ashley she told her she
tried to help you she said she heard you
calling out so that was someone else
then interesting yay you better go in
button bound chicka wow wow alright
yes did he make it you need to listen me
I don't care if you believe me or not
doesn't matter because you will you need
to go down to the mines what's in the
mind Sam
I've seen what's down there I'd give
anything done see it and why would she
tell them to go down that's kind of a
dick move all right let's look dude we
got a movie now cuz the last movie we
got was of Josh and it was pretty lame
we don't even get a movie why I'm so
glad I did that [ __ ] oh boy my god
why didn't it just change okay you know
what I [ __ ] tried and yeah it's a
shame because you can't skip in the
chapters and [ __ ] like that but that
there you go there standing with
everyone except Chris and Matt but we're
kind of my favorite but sometimes in
life you just got to move on and be okay
with it all right I did this for your
brows and didn't turn out the way we
wanted but at least I tried so I hope
that's worth something for you alright
that's the end of until dawn Thank You
brothers again a million times over for
supporting this series I really did try
my best to to get the best kind of
possibilities for what it's worth I
really really enjoyed it and I hope we
boost it as well so again I'll see you
brush in the next video or series that
we're gonna do it's gonna be a lot more
series coming up so definitely don't
miss out on that stay awesome ruff
[Music]